NIGHT.
♪.
GREG: IT IS TRUE, OUR PRESIDENT
TAKES DRUGS.
>> HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, RIGHT
NOW.
I WAS JUST WAITING TO SEE YOUR
EYES LIGHT UP WHEN I SAID THIS.
WHEN I ANNOUNCED THIS.
>> I HAVE BEEN TAKEN FOR A WEEK
AND A HALF, EVERY DAY, I TAKE A
PILL EVERY DAY.
GREG: THE PRESIDENT DID THE
UNTHINKABLE, HE TOLD YOU HE WAS
TAKEN A DRUG PRESCRIBED TO HIM
BY WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR.
WHY, HE TELLS US EVERYTHING.
IN THE MEDIAS BRAINS BUBBLED
LIKE CRACK EGGS ON A BUBBLED
SIDEWALK.
>> THE PRESENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SAYS HE’S TAKING DRUGS TO
PREVENT CORONAVIRUS AND THE FDA
WARNS IS DANGEROUS AND STUDY
AFTER STUDY SHOWS IS USELESS
AGAINST THE VIRUS.
>> HE IS TAKING AN UNPROVEN DRUG
THAT MEDICAL EXPERTS WARN CAN
HAVE HARMFUL SIDE EFFECTS.
THIS IS REALLY DEADLY SERIOUS.
IT IS QUITE DANGEROUS.
>> WHY DOES HE BRING UP
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, I DON’T EVEN
KNOW THESE REALLY TAKEN.
GREG: THAT IS JUST WHAT THEY
SAID BETWEEN TOKES.
REMEMBER TRUMP AND NOT SAID HE
WAS TAKEN OVERPRICED EXOTIC
ROUTE FROM THE RAIN FOREST THAT
GWYNETH PALTROW SAYS LOOSEN HER
CHAP WRIST.
HE WAS NOT LICKING ACID OFTEN
AMAZON FRAUD RESCUED FROM JOE
ROGAN’S ISOLATION TANK.
HE TOOK A RELIABLE DRUG UNDER
THE BEST SUPERVISION THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND A HALF A CENTURY.
WHAT EXACTLY DID CHRIS CUOMO
TAKE?
>> HE MOCKED THE PRESIDENT FOR
THIS, INTERESTINGLY I FOUND THIS
OUT JUST BEFORE COMING HERE,
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE INVOICES AND
FDA APPROVED MEDICATION WITH A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD FOR SAFETY
AND IT TURNS OUT THAT CHRIS
CUOMO TOOK A LESS SAFE VERSION
WHICH THE FDA REMOVED FROM THE
MARKET IN 2006 BECAUSE OF
SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS INCLUDING
DEATH.
TO HAVE THE CRITICISM OF THE
PRESIDENT.
GREG: SHE IS GOOD.
CUOMO IS A HYPOCRISY MACHINE,
DON’T BREAK QUARANTINE.
THEN HE DOES, DON’T TAKE RISKY
MEDS, THEN HE DOES.
HE ACCUSES PEOPLE NOT TAKING THE
VIRUS SERIOUSLY AND THEN HE DOES
THIS.
>> IS IT TRUE THAT THIS WAS A
SWAB THAT THE NURSE WAS ACTUALLY
USING ON YOU AND AT FIRST IT
WENT INTO YOUR NOSE AND
DISAPPEARED SO IN SCALE, THIS
WAS THE ACTUAL SWAB THAT WAS
BEING USED TO FIT UP THE DOUBLE
BARREL SHOTGUN THAT YOU HAVE
MOUNTED ON THE FRONT OF YOUR
PRETTY FACE.
GREG: HE’S A BIRTHDAY MAGICIAN
ON DRUGS.
^-CARET TOP I KNOW YOU ARE
WATCHING, SOMEONE BROKE INTO
YOUR CROP CLOSET, CALL THE COPS.
I DON’T MIND MISSING UNDER
MIXING HUMOR WITH NEWS, THE NEWS
HAS NOT BEEN GOOD FOR THE
ELDERLY WHO DIED BY THE
THOUSANDS UNDER GOVERNOR CUOMO
AND WHAT DID THE PRESS DO, THEY
LIONIZED HIM BECAUSE OF THE
ADORABLE CNN ROUTINES.
IMAGINE IF I PULLED OUT A GIANT
SWAB.
CNN WOULD CONDEMN IT AND CAN
DIFFERENCE TO DEATH.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT CHRIS OR DON LEMON, WHAT
ARE THEY, NEWS, COMMENTARY, PROP
COMICS.
I DO COMMENTARY, BRET BAIER DOES
NEWS THEN WE HOT TUB LIKE
CRAVING BEAST.
BUT CNN IS A GARBAGE SALAD,
DOING COMMENTARY IS NEWS.
AS THE MEDIA GUSHED OVER ANDY,
THEY SMEARED THE GOVERNOR WHO
HAD ENOUGH.
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
YOUR PROFESSION WHO WHACK
POETICALLY FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS
ABOUT HALF ORDER WAS GOING TO BE
JUST LIKE NEW YORK, WAIT TWO
WEEKS FOR THE WILL BE NEXT, WE
ARE EIGHT WEEKS AWAY FROM THAT
AND HAS NOT HAPPENED.
GREG: I THINK WHATEVER TRUMP HAS
IS CONTAGIOUS, IT IS NOT CORONA
BUT COJONES.
DID YOU HEAR TRUMP DID NOT WEAR
HIS MASK BRIEFLY IN MICHIGAN.
SOME PEOPLE PUT IN PERSPECTIVE,
EXCEPT THIS LOON.
IS THE PRESIDENT NO LONGER
WELCOME IN MICHIGAN?
>> I WILL SAY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF MY DEPARTMENT AND MY OFFICE,
THE PRESIDENT IS LIKE A CHILD
WHO REFUSES TO FOLLOW THE RULES,
HE IS A RIDICULOUS PERSON AND I
AM ASHAMED TO HAVE HIM BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
I HOPE THAT THE VOTERS OF
MICHIGAN WILL REMEMBER THIS WHEN
NOVEMBER COMES, HE DID NOT CARE
ENOUGH ABOUT THEIR SAFETY OR
THEIR WELFARE.
GREG: NICE WORK CRAZY LADY.
NOW TO THE GUY WHO BRUTALIZED AN
ELDERLY PERSON IN A MICHIGAN
NURSING HOME, WHERE WAS THE CARE
AND SAFETY AND THAT, SHE FREAKS
OUT ABOUT THE MASK BUT NOT THAT
IN HER OWN STATE.
NICE PRIORITIES YOU JOKE.
IT’S FUNNY WATCHING PEOPLE LIKE
HER AND REPORTERS GO AFTER TRUMP
FOR NOT WEARING A MASK AS THEY
ARE NOT WEARING A MASK EITHER.
APPARENTLY THEIR MESSAGE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE PRESIDENTS.
MEANWHILE LEFT-WING WRITER SAID
THIS WEEK SHE WOULD VOTE
PROVIDED, EVEN IF HE ATE BABIES.
HOW DOES ONE RESPOND, CLEARLY
SHE’S NOT A VEGAN, SHAME ON HER.
SHE CAN GET AWAY WITH SAYING
THAT BECAUSE IT’S NOT OFFENSIVE
TO HER PEERS BECAUSE SHE SAID
BABY, SHE DID NOT SAY BLACK
BABY, GAY BABY, TRANS BABY, THAT
WOULD’VE BEEN TOO FAR BUT THE
GENERIC BABY IS OKAY.
ESPECIALLY SINCE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD GOT 80 MILLION FROM
THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION PLAN
WHICH WAS SMALL BUSINESSES
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
HOW IS AMERICA’S LARGEST
ABORTION BUSINESS SMALL?
I GET IT, THEIR VICTIMS ARE.
IS THE MEDIA CONCERNED ABOUT
TRUMP’S HELP, NO.
THE MEDIA LOVES KNOWING THINGS
THAT YOU DON’T BOW INVALIDATES A
SUPERIORITY FOR THE INSECURE
ELITE CLASS.
IT IS WHY THEY BANK AT THE
THOUGHT OF TAKEN ANTIMALARIAL
PILL BUT EAT SHROOMS BY THE
POUND, 20 THINK NUCLEAR POWELL
UNDER POWER IS EVIL THE CRYSTAL
HEALING.
THE MEDIA LOVES TO BOAST ABOUT
THE HOT BROADWAY PLAY, YOU
CANNOT GET TICKETS TO FOR A
YEAR, THEY TRIED TO OUT HAMILTON
EACH OTHER, DID YOU GET TICKETS,
GATHER SO EXPENSIVE, WE GOT
THROUGH IT WITH A FRIEND OF A
FRIEND.
THEY LOVE THE PRIEST STUFF, THE
SECRET STUFF, THE STUFF THEY GET
ILLEGALLY AND WILL NEVER SHARE
WITH YOU BUT TRUMP IS OPPOSITE.
IF YOU LIKE SOMETHING, HE WILL
TELL YOU ABOUT IT, HE IS NOT
ABOVE YOU AND THAT IS WEIRD.
THE JURY IS OUT ON THIS DRUG,
SEEMS USELESS AT THE IN-STATE
BUT MAY BE HELPFUL IN THE EARLY
PHASE.
IT’S A LINE OF DEFENSE THAT
YOU’D OBSESSED WITH YOUR
DOCTORS, NOT WITH IDIOTS LIKE
ME.
YOU CANNOT BUY IT AT GNC, IT IS
PRESCRIBED BY A DOCTOR.
NOT A POLITICIAN.
NO WONDER NANCY IS TICKED.
>> OUR PRESIDENT AND I WOULD
RATHER HIM NOT BE TAKING
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
APPROVED BY THE SCIENTIST
ESPECIALLY IN HIS AGE GROUP AND
SHALL WE SAY HIS WEIGHT GROUP
WHICH IS MORBIDLY OBESE.
GREG: THAT’S A PRETTY GOOD JOKE.
NOW TO JERRY NADLER OR TO STACY,
JUST KIDDING, YOU CAN ONLY FAT
SHAME SOME PEOPLE.
BUT SHE HAS GAME AND JOE BIDEN
CAN LEARN FROM HER.
>> NANCY, I NEED NEW NICKNAMES
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
I LIKE PRESIDENT TWEETING, THE
BIRD, THEY’RE BOTH ORANGE.
>> MORBIDLY OBESE.
>> WE NEED MORE HYPHENS IN THEIR
THEIR.
>> STILL TOO SHORT, I LIKE MY
INSULTS LONG LIKE A HANDILY
MODEL ON.
>> HOW ABOUT PRESIDENTIAL OBESE
LYING RUSSIAN RACIST SOLDIER.
>> PONY SOLDIER.
THAT HITS HIM, MAKES THE HAIR ON
MY LEG STAND UP.
REACHING AND TOUCHING.
ON, REAL QUICK, I’LL CLOSE MY
EYES.
>> I MEAN I’M IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> SAN FRAN IN THE GOLDEN STATE
BRIDGE.
HOLD ON.
GOTTA GO THAT IS HUNTER.
GREG: BANANA SHOULD NOT BE
NAILING TRUMP FOR MANAGING HIS
OWN HEALTH UNLESS SHE HAS BETTER
INFO THAN HIS DOCK.
IT IS CUTE HOWARD DEAN OVER
CLASSES GO AFTER A PERSON TAKEN
ILLEGAL DRUG DURING THE PANDEMIC
TRADE WHAT IF HE SAID HE LOVED
BOTOX AND ADDERALL, THE ENTIRE
PRESS WOULD HAVE TO QUIT BOTH
THEY WOULD GET NOTHING DONE BUT
CRYING.
THE GOOD NEWS WE BELIEVE LIFE IS
GETTING GOOD AGAIN, CASES ARE
DRAMATICALLY DECLINING IN A NEW
GALLUP POLL SHOWS PEOPLE ARE
HAPPIER MORE THAN A MONTH AGO.
THEY SENSE GOOD THINGS AND
AGAIN, A WRINKLE CREAM, THE
PERSPECTIVE FROM THE MISERY
MEDIA THAT YOU SEE GRAHAM
HORIZONS BEYOND THE STRETCHED
BASIS.
WE KNOW WE’VE DONE GREAT BUT
WERE DONE HIDING AND LEAVING IT
TO THE MEDIA AND THEIR LIES.
IT IS TIME TO GET UP, GO OUTSIDE
AND GET TO WORK.
WE CAN DO THIS, WE ALREADY HAVE,
IT’S PRETTY SIMPLE, WASH YOUR
HANDS A LOT, PUT ON A MASK A
LOT, DON’T HUG STRANGERS,
PROTECT THE ELDERLY AND GET TO
WORK UNLESS YOU’RE THE MEDIA.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD SIT THIS ONE
OUT, YOU’VE DONE ENOUGH DAMAGE,